We’ve located the roots of the zombi in
spiritual beliefs developed during
from the African diaspora, looked at
the Haitian zombi/pop culture zombie dichotomy,
and the role slavery played in how the monster was
shaped—and why it took hold in popular culture.
Now we can explore one of the most influential
and enduring horror legacies of all time—
the Romero zombie.
Pause with music up and animation
You simply can’t talk about
zombies without talking about...
….George A. Romero. Spanning 41 years,
his six-part zombie series (plus
two remakes!) introduced the
world to an evolving vision
and version of the monsters, starting
in 1968 with Night of the Living Dead.
Slow moving, flesh-eating, and very clearly
undead, the zombies presented in this first
film impacted horror movies in ways that still
resonate today, and absolutely contributed to
Romero’s reputation as one of the most
significant directors of the genre.
More than just the reinvention of
a frightening fiend, the Romero
zombie’s introduction during a time of great
political and cultural unrest in America
impacted how it was received—and
why we still talk about it.
Whether it’s what he intended or not, Romero’s
work forever changed the way we look at zombies.
[Monstrum intro.]
Before we get into
the details of the film that put Romero on
the map, let’s talk about why his specific
portrayal of zombies is so notorious that
they get their own title (and video!).
After all, Romero wasn’t the first person
to show undead bodies eating living human
flesh. But you could call him the Bram Stoker
of zombies—he took bits and pieces of existing
lore and mythology and combined them together
into one iconic monster for the first time.
Romero zombies are reanimated corpses
that crave human flesh, and literally
anyone can become one. They are almost always
slow-moving and in some cases can even use
tools. They can be destroyed by a shot to the head
or a heavy blow to the skull. No clear explanation
is ever given for why they returned from the
grave and unlike the Haitian zombi, Romero’s
creations are autonomous and even sometimes
self-aware; they answer to no human master.
We can pretty confidently say that
Romero’s zombie looked so different
because he wasn’t really aware
of the Haitian zombi tradition.
Just ask Daniel Kraus, the author who
finished Romero’s novel The Living Dead.
I'm not convinced he knew much about Haitian
zombies. He wasn't even thinking
about these as zombies at all.
But he was just trying to create something
that would, that would be the chaos outside
the farmhouse.
Um, so I don't think that shift really existed
in his mind. I don't know that the concept of
the Haitian zombie was well enough known in America
for there to be that conscious of a shift.
Romero claims that it was another type of undead
creature that inspired him—the vampires in
Richard Matheson’s I Am Legend, a
book about a city ravaged by a virus.
In Night of the Living Dead, what we would
now identify as a zombie is actually called
a “ghoul.” Romero eventually called the monsters
zombies, only because other people did.
I think some of it happened kind of, especially
with George Romero happened sort of organically.
And it's almost like after the fact
once they started being called zombies,
which would have been sometime, I
guess, early seventies or something,
certainly by Dawn of the Dead
they're calling them zombies.
Night of the Living Dead, is one of the most
culturally and critically acclaimed contributions
to the zombie canon. The film follows a group
of survivors sheltering in a farmhouse in rural
Pennsylvania after escaping from an attack by
suddenly-and-inexplicably-resurrected corpses.
The movie is centered around the characters
of Barbara, a woman in a catatonic state as
a result of seeing her brother killed
and another woman half-eaten, and
Ben, the competent, resourceful
man who tries to save her.
Tension builds as the two leads
find themselves at odds with the
competing personalities and interests of
the other survivors sheltering with them.
Sounds like a traditional
set-up for a horror film,
right? So why did this film have
so much impact and staying power?
To get more insight into the Romero zombie,
I had a conversation with Tananarive Due,
a screenwriter, author, and
executive producer of Horror Noire.
This film conceived and shot and the tumultuous
1960s against the backdrop
of the civil rights era,
which much like our contemporary era had really
disturbing images coming across people's screens.
So I don't think it's a surprise that
the 1960s in particular produced the more
violent zombies that would actually
invade your home. It's almost as if
the violence on your television screen has
been brought to life and is trying to kill you.
he was shooting night, living dead, um,
in the style of news footage and that was
conscious. Um, and he was basing it off of footage
and photographs of protesters being beat up
that was conscious. So all these, you know,
all these decisions prove who the man is.
Emily from Tananarive Due Interview:
For me, the two scenes that stuck out
the most were Ben being shot and
the little girl eating her mother,
I interpret that as also
sort of an uprising of youth
culture and like a very violent visceral way.
You know, we see this child devouring,
her mother represents it is just the world
turned upside down. And as a kid watching
that, it's really horrifying because, uh,
you're engaging with the question of
how much violence is a child capable of and,
and, and this idea of being parentless,
being orphan.
The final scene of the movie depicts Ben, thelone survivor among the farmhouse’s inhabitants,
and also the lone Black man in the entire film,
being shot in the head by a member
of an all-white rescue squad.
The town sheriff gives the order when he
mistakes Ben for one of the reanimated dead.
The rescuers who basically look like a Lynch
mob to not look like saviors to me as a black
person. And sure enough, Duane Jones is shot
without even a word without even thought.
...His history is erased. His heroism erased.
Just had to really really stun a lot of audiences.
Now, Romero consistently refuted that he meant to
make any connection between the murder of Ben and
the Civil Rights movement sweeping America at
the time. He insisted that he cast Duane Jones,
the only black actor in the film,
because he had had the best audition.
Even if you weren't thinking about racial strife
and the power difference between whites and
blacks, when you cast Duane Jones, I have to think
that when he was looking at the daily footage,
he had to be struck by the image of this dark
skin, black man taking charge throughout this
movie, uh, punching Mr. Cooper, who definitely
represents the white patriarchy of the day
In 1960s America it seems impossible that
this moment would not have been seen as a
statement about Black power.
I don't think there were any black
zombies in Night of the Living Dead.
So he is killing white person after white person
after white person. I don't understand how you
can be looking at that footage and not realize,
wow, this is really going to hit people hard,
this is going to hit people where it hurts.
The years preceding the release of the movie
itself were politically and socially
charged with conversations about race.
Brown v. Board of Education, declaring racial
segregation of schools unconstitutional,
had been passed only 14 years before.
Ten years after Brown v. Board and only four
years before Romero’s film was released,
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 had
outlawed discrimination based on sex,
nationality, religion, color, and race.
Loving v. Virginia had given interracial
couples the legal right to wed in 1967
and that same year Star Trek featured the
first interracial kiss on television.
Of course Romero, who shot the film in
1967, could not have predicted that the
assassination of Martin Luther King, Jr. would
occur the same year the movie was released.
This is Dr. Robin Means Coleman,
professor and author of Horror Noire.
It's 1968, he's driving to New York,
he's got these film cans in the car,
in the trunk of the car, and he hears it.
Dr. Martin Luther King, the apostle of
non-violence and the Civil Rights movement
has been shot to death in Memphis Tennessee.
..And you have to think that he knows that he
knows what he has in the trunk of his car,
that he has a film that is already whether,
you know, he overtly understands it or
claims it is a brilliant piece of art,
but also human and political history.
It is notable that when the
movie was re-released in 1969,
it was advertised as a double-feature alongside
other movies that were explicitly about race,
like Slaves.
Despite Romero’s denial of any
intentional racial allegories,
Duane Jones appears to have
had a different perspective.
The original script described the character
of Ben as a white, redneck truck driver.
But Jones insisted that the character’s speech
and wardrobe should be more sophisticated.
Romero even said that Jones “didn’t want to
look gruff and he wanted to be presentable.
He was the one who was much more worried
about any of that then we were.”
Finally, having heard Night of the Living Dead
called a political film time and time again,
Romero seemingly relented. He acknowledged that he
may have unconsciously had certain themes in mind.
This is an important, powerful text if for
no other reason that it emerges right in the,
in the sort of context of King's assassination
and says, you will see, and appreciate
the power, the resonance of blackness. That's
what makes Night of the Living Dead so special.
George has great affection for his human characters, but he essentially saw them as doomed
and maybe as the human race was sort of deservedly doomed and that we had to make way for this uprising
So it was always intended as an uprising narrative.
Romero’s next zombie movie, Dawn of the
Dead, came out in 1978, and portrayed the
same type of zombie, but moved the setting to a
shopping mall—then a growing site of importance
in American consumer culture and a symbol of
mass culture and homogenous suburban life.
The movie opens in a newsroom where the media
becomes the target of Romero’s social critique.
The news anchor says he does not believe
the doctor being interviewed despite the
professional’s insistence that the dead
have risen and begun attacking the living.
In a downtown setting SWAT team officers
gun down housing project residents seemingly
indiscriminately before a group
of survivors flees the city in a helicopter.
They seek shelter in a large shopping
center where zombies roam outside,
drawn by some memory of the
place having significance.
The humor and ridiculousness of some of
the scenes in Dawn of the Dead reflect the
comedic over- exaggeration and gore
endemic to late 70s horror movies.
Dawn spawned this entire genre that was bigger and
brighter, and had these elements of joy in it that
were missing from the earlier zombie works,
so I think it just was the perfect kind of
film at the perfect time in
the seventies. That really just
is the kind of thing that
makes fan boys and fan girls.
It made him to the godfather of the zombies.
Dawn of the Dead was followed by Day of the Dead
in 1985, in which science takes a front-seat as
military personnel and scientists attempt to stop
or reverse zombification in an underground bunker.
Of course, there’s a doctor performing strange
experiments on the undead—another trope Romero
helped to establish in the zombie genre.
Interestingly, Romero would later say
that Day of the Dead was unique for its use of
the zombie Bub as the film’s main character.
Bub defies zombie norms by showing
some level of intelligence,
since he is trained to not act violently.
He’s friendly to most of the living characters
and remembers some parts of his previous life.
He even speaks and shoots a gun at one point.
Bub marks the first, but not the last,
of Romero’s zombies who appear capable of
domestication. Romero is humanizing the undead.
A sign that the zombie was changing, both in
meaning and popularity, was clearly demonstrated
in the 1990 Night of the Living Dead remake.
Romero rewrote the original script
himself, which featured key changes
like making Barbara actually capable
of contributing to her own survival.
The establishment of stronger female
characters in horror and action movies
since the 1970s and the feminist movement can
account for Barbara’s altered character arc.
Romero even said that 90’s Barbara was “his
apology to women” for the 1968 original character.
Ben is still killed, but only
after he has become a zombie,
justifying his death, and seems to be an
attempt to remove any racial commentary.
The dramatic cultural and social differences
between the late 20th and early 21st centuries
are also reflected in the 2004 remake of
Dawn of the Dead. Like all Romero films, this
“reimagining” as the creators like to call it, is
profoundly reflective of its place in history.
While still set in a mall, the opening scenes
of the zombie attacks and instant apocalyptic
chaos of the undead is jarring to Americans. -
And let’s be honest, those scenes of the undead
swarming the mall and banging on the
doors read differently once you’ve seen
those videos of how people can get
2005 saw the release of Land of the Dead,
set in Pittsburgh where the safety of the
living is ensured by a feudal-like government.
Romero’s application of the zombie film as
social commentary is again on full display
as the survivors with money and power live in a
luxury apartment building while the majority of
the population lives in slums. Oh, and suburbia?
Yeah, that’s been completely overrun by zombies.
For me this film stands out because
of the character of Big Daddy—a
Black zombie hero with intelligence, who leads
the other zombies and uses tools. He also
figures out that zombies can walk underwater
and use machine guns, so that’s terrifying.
The movie ends with Big Daddy and a group of
his undead followers leaving the city and not
attacking the living, which to me reads as another
homage to I Am Legend as well as Romero again
alluding to the ascension of a new generation
that uses ingenuity and makes the best out of
bad circumstances. Perhaps this is also an
intentional contrast with the violent end of
the Black character in Night of the Living Dead.
In 2007, Diary of the Dead introduced us to a
group of college film students navigating the
zombie apocalypse with the aid of their only
source of up-to-date information—bloggers on the
Internet. This penultimate Romero zombie film
explored analogies including our eroding social
connections, the effect of emerging technologies
on our bodies and our brains, and the collapse
of civilization in a post-apocalyptic setting.
Indeed, as technology advances, it is increasingly
presented as threatening to our very humanity,
and even in some cases, the
direct cause of a zombie plague
Romero definitely wanted to make this
connection in Diary of the Dead.
In an interview, he said that the film was in
part inspired by his concern of the explosion of
“alternate media, the blogosphere and all that,
and it just occurred to me that there’s some
dangers lying here potentially hidden. It just
really struck me that this was what was going on
in the world now, everyone’s a camera, everyone’s
a reporter, and people seem to be obsessed by it.”
The last zombie film Romero wrote and directed,
Survival of the Dead, premiered in 2009
and focuses on two families whose mutual
hostility and loathing -- diseases of the mind and
soul -- long predate the arrival of the zombie
infection. The movie culminates in a gruesome
scene in which the two reanimated patriarchs
attempt to kill each other—again. Clearly,
the zombies are a backdrop, a foil for festering
social, personal, and political conflict.
I think that one of the reasons zombies
become so popular in recent years is again
the kind of a retread of that fear of social
upheaval that we saw in the 1960s. You only have
to open a newspaper or watch a news program today
to see the fears represented by the segment
of the population that is afraid of change.
That doesn't like the way the nation looks,
because it doesn't look as white as they thought
it's supposed to look. And that segment of the
population that's afraid because they're being
targeted because of their race and, and, and in
policing and in mass incarceration. So I think all
of those fears are kind of at a, at a boil.
That’s what Romero’s real legacy is:
he created a monster whose genesis is
vague and whose manifestation is rot,
and juxtaposed it with American society at the
turn of the 21st century. His zombies have,
from the beginning, represented so much more
than just mindless flesh-eating automatons.
He had done night and Dawn and
that alone was going to make him
a legend. And it didn't hurt that he was, you
know, 11 feet tall and wore giant black glasses
and was just incredibly amiable. Um, he, he
was a perfect Emissary for horror, and the way
that the people who created can be extremely
approachable and gentle and kind Ramiro was a
pacifist. He might've made these violent movies,
but they were all in aid of his, his beliefs
and his politics, which were largely, you
know, learn how to walk away from a fight.
In a 2010 interview Romero said
he largely thinks his movies are
“overanalyzed” and he’s “not into it.” But, I
don’t think he’s giving himself enough credit.
Regardless of the original intentions of the
filmmaker, ultimately the audience gets to
decide what it means. Our own experiences
and perspectives influence how we interpret
any kind of art, including zombie films.
So to end, I’ll use the late,
great horror icon’s own words: “All the
monsters we’ve created in fiction, unless
expressly identified as the Devil, represent our
own evil. We create them so we can kill them off,
thereby justifying ourselves—it’s
a kind of penance, self-exorcism.”